جائزه خاصه حصل عليها الفيلم اليمني
المرهقون في مهرجان برلين السينمائي كاكثر
الافلام تاثيرا على الجانب الانسانيه
الفيلم اليمني ايضا جائزه منظمه العفو
الدوليه حاصلا على ثاني اعلى نسبه تصويت
في جائزه الجمهور تدور احداث حول زوجين
يعانيان الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه في
اليمن ولديهما ثلاثه اطفال ومع اكتشاف
الزوجه بحملها من جديد تبدا في التفكير في
اجهاض حملها الفيلم من اخراج عمرو جمال
وبطوله خالد حمدان وعبير محمد وسمح
العمراني واسلام سليم ورؤى الهمشري وعمر
الياس
لا عادوا بكره الداخليه والجيش
[موسيقى]
عسوله حبيبي
مش عارفه
الله اعلم
ينضم الينا على كل المساعد المخرج في فيلم
المراهقون مروان مفرق مروان اهلا بك يسعد
صباحك معانا مبروك فوز في المرهقون بجائزه
منظمه العفو الدوليه في مهرجان برلين
السينمائي حدثنا اولا عن فكره الف
صباح الخير عليكم جميعا
الفيلم ده كان يعني
صديق لنا عالم بعد الحرب من مشاكل
اجتماعيه مشاكل اقتصاديه بحكم ما انتم
عارفين الحرب
الطبقه الوسط تقريبا في عدن وفي اليمن ككل
الانهيار ادى الى
يعني يعني مشاكل اجتماعيه كبيره تخيلي ان
الفرده تقريبا كان في قبل 2015 دخلت الفرد
اذا قلنا مئه ريال مئه الف ريال كانت
تعادل حوالي 400 دولار الان دخل الفرد نزل
عن 80 دولار 60 دولار
مشكله كبيره يعني
الوضع الاقتصادي مرهون بالوضع الامني غير
المستقر اصلا في اليمن فبالتالي اكيد كانت
مهمه التصوير صعبه ما الصعوبات والتحديات
التي واجهتكم اثناء التصوير الفيلم
بالنسبه لنا من من سابقه عدن بالنسبه لنا
استوديو مفتوح كلها بترحب باي عمل فني
البيوت بتفتح ابوابها لكنها ما ننكرش انه
فعلا الباب على الامني له اثر خصوصا انه
في خلال التصوير حصلت مواجهات مع اطراف
خارجه عن القانون واضطرينا ايقاف التصوير
لعده ايام لكن الحمد لله بعد كذا باش
العمل
ومن البدايه احنا واحنا بنعاني من كل
جوانب الحياه يعني عشان الحمد لله
طيب مروان يعني لو نتحدث عن التركيز في
هذا الفيلم هل كان كان فكره الفيلم
التركيز على جردليه الاجهاض في المجتمع
اليمني ام التركيز على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه التي تدفع الناس للتخلي عن
احلامهم
يلا طبعا رمزيه
رمزيه فقط زي ما طالع جمال من السابق ان
احنا في لغتنا العربيه دائما بنجيب
بنمثل بالاجهاض وكانه احلامنا اجهضت
واستقبلنا ابهر
رمزيه بشكل اساسي الى حاله طيب مروان
اليوم الى اي حد انسنت القضيه صوتها اعلى
من صوت المعركه وبالتالي تخاطبون فيها
العالم والغرب
لازم
السينما مرات الشعوب وهي توثق لمراحل
حياتيه في
بلدان كثيره
والان عبر
عبر السينما صوت الانسان بيوصل اكثر من
صوت
البندق والحب عشان كده اعتقد ان انا
لامسنا قلوب العديد من الناس الذين شاهدوا
فيلم في مهرجان لذلك
وصل
التصويت الجمهور لنا في المركز الثاني
تقريبا وهواء وهي جائزه انا اراها يعني من
اهم الجوائز
لكن اكثر ما اثار الاعجاب الجمهور العالمي
كان
حرص المخرج على اظهار اللقطات الطبيعيه في
عدن ولقطات بانوراميه تحرص على اظهار
معالم تاريخيه في عدن ما كانت ما الرساله
من وراء ذلك
رسالتنا بشكل اساسي ان عدم بتنوعها الدين
والثقافي من من عصور قديم يعني تتكلمي عن
مدينه اذا تكلمنا التي مساحتها حول سبعه
متر سبعه كيلو متر مربع تحتوي على هذه
المدينه على كنائس على معابد وعلى
عالم تاريخيه متنوعه جدا بسبب الحروب التي
مرت عليها اغلبها تعرض للاهمال والتدمير
لذلك نحن نحاول ان احنا
نلحق يعني بما يقول ونوثق من
الباقي من المدينه
طب ومروان ماذا يعني لكم تواجد فيلم يمني
سينمائي في احد اكبر مهرجانات السينما
العالميه على الاطلاق لاول مره
هو تتويج لظهود
ول طموحنا كل صدق احنا من زمان بنحاول
نحاول ندخل مجال السينما لكن كل شيء بوقته
حلو بعد 14 سنه تقريبا من العمل الفني
اقرر دخول
مضمار السينما والحمد لله بعد كلمه قبل
الزفه قبل في عام 2018
بالتوفيق دائما شكرا جزيلا لك مساعد مخرج
في فيلم المراهقون مروان مفرق كان معنا من
عدن